I tend to believe that there's alien
civilizations dispersed all throughout
yeah but we might be totally isolated
from them so you think we're not there's
none in this galaxy
so like and I guess and the question I
also have is what kind of do you think
they have nuclear fusion
because like is it all because the
physics all the same yeah oh the physics
is all the same yeah right so this is
the and this is the Fermi Paradox like
where where the hell is everybody in the
universe right
um well there's some so you know the
scariest one of those is that I would
point out that there's been you know
there's you know order of many tens of
millions of species on the planet Earth
and only one ever got to the point of
sophisticated tool use that we could
actually start essentially leveraging
the power of what what's in nature to
our own will does this mean that
basically this means so almost look
there is almost certainly life or DNA
equivalence or whatever would be
somewhere I mean just because you just
need a soup and you need energy and you
get Organics and whatever the equivalent
of amino acids are but you know most of
life on Earth has been that those are
still amazing but it's still like it's
not very interesting are we are we
actually the accident of History this is
a very interesting one they're super
rare super rare and then of course the
other part is that also just the other
scary part of it which is if you look at
the fairy paradoxes good good we got to
this point how long has it been in
humans so humans Homo Sapien has been
around for whatever 100 000 years 200
000 years
um our ability in in that timeline to
actually make an imprint on the universe
like for by emitting radio waves or by
modifying you know in nature in a
significant way has only been for about
a hundred of those hundred thousand
years
and you know are we it's a good question
so is it by definition that by the fact
that when you are able to reach that
level of being able to manipulate nature
and for example discover you know
discover like fission or or or other or
or burning fossil fuels and all this is
that what it says oh you're doomed
because by definition any species that
gets to that point that can modify their
environment like that they'll actually
push themselves
you know past that's that's one of the
most depressing scenarios that I can
imagine yeah so the the so basically
we're we will never line up in time
because you get this little teeny window
in time over civilization might occur
and you you can never see it because you
never these these sort of like scatter
like like fireflies around the Galaxy
and you never yeah yeah
and then explodes it destroys itself
because of the and when we say destroy
ourselves all would have to do is that
we basically go if you humans are all
left and we're still living on the
planet and but all we have to do is go
to the technology of like you know 1800
yeah and we're invisible in the universe
again
yeah he so it was when I when I listened
to the part I I thought I wanted to talk
about this as well too because this it
comes from well it comes from a science
point of view actually of what it means
but also to me it's like another
compelling driver of telling us it's
like why we should try really hard not
to screw this up like we're in this
unique place of our ability to discover
and make it and I just don't want to
give up about thinking that we can get
through yeah I tend to see that there is
some kind of game theoretic Force like
with Demetrius shared destruction that
ultimately in each human being there's a
desire to survive and a willingness to
cooperate yeah to have compassion for
each other in order to survive and I
think that I mean maybe not in humans
but I can imagine nearly infinite number
of species in which
that overpowers
any uh technological advancement that
can destroy or rewind the species so I
think if humans fail
I hope they don't
I see a lot of evidence for them not but
it seems like somebody will survive and
there you start to ask questions about
why why we haven't met yet maybe it's
just the space is large oh spaces it's I
I think in logarithms and I can't even
fathom this you know space this is
extraordinary right yeah it's
extraordinarily large yeah I mean
there's so many places on Earth I just
recently visited Paris for the first
time yeah and there's so many other
places I haven't visited there's so many
other places well I like to you know
it's interesting that we have this
fascination with alien life we have what
is essentially alien life on Earth
already like you think about the
organisms that develop around deep sea
like thermal vents one of my favorite
books of all time from Stephen J Gould
if you've never read that book it kind
of blows your mind it's about the
Cambrian explosion of life and it's like
oh you look at these things and it's
like our the chance of us existing as a
species like the the genetic diverse
city was larger back then you know this
is about five about 500 million years
ago or something like that it is a
mind-altering trip of thinking about our
place in the universe I have to say plus
the Mind itself yeah is a kind of alien
but almost
um
almost a mystery to ourselves we still
don't understand it the very the very
mechanism that helps us explore the
world is still a mystery yeah so that
like understanding that will also unlock
um a quite quite possibly unlock our
ability to understand the world and
maybe build machines that help us in the
world build tools then I mean it already
has I mean our ability to understand the
world is is ridiculous almost Ashley
[Laughter]